That about wraps up our exploration with some different tools that are helpful with mechanical rigging specifically.
But I just wanted to briefly touch on a few more useful tools that are available in Control Rig,
that we don't have time to look at within this course, but might help you out when you're building your own Control Rigs.
So you can create your own function libraries, which is essentially a way to package up sections of logic within your Rig Graph
into a custom function. And you can then share that across all of the Control Rigs in your project just by setting it public.
Just the same as how the standard function library was created that comes with the engine,
where we've been using functions like the Jiggle function, the FK chain and the local chain dynamics functions.
And this can just be super helpful essentially to speed things up when you're creating your rigs.
There are also a bunch of nodes and functions that enable you to create splines and attach bones to them.
And you can create these procedurally using the construction event,
which give you a pretty interesting way of controlling the bones within your mesh and can really increase the flexibility of your rig.
Now something that's really cool about Control Rig is the hierarchy of your controls isn't necessarily fixed,
which means at runtime you're able to dynamically update the hierarchy,
giving you a greater degree of control and enabling you to set up the control systems that you wouldn't be able to otherwise.
Control Rig also has a very useful debug mode, which has a bunch of features available to help you track down any issues with your rig and get them fixed.
So two very useful features for this are breakpoints,
which allow you to just step through the logic of your rig graph and find out where things might be going wrong so you can fix them.
And visual profiling, which is essentially a visual representation, kind of like a heat map of how costly something might be in terms of computational expense,
which is going to help you understand how expensive different features and functions are to help you optimize your rigs.
And you can access this specifically from the class settings, so under the VM runtime heading, if you just tick enable profiling, that'll give you access to this.